I would say in the last five years I see
more and more inventors that understand
the value of Ip strategy in their
business
and when you meet such a client it's a
great pleasure because you know there is
a true communication
we understand what is the you know what
the sea level executive want and we try
to build you know IP roadmet which will
be meet their business goal welcome to
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
C-Tech
[Music]
[Applause]
Woody I'm really excited to to talk to
you you know about your your journey or
perspective quite and really interesting
Journey living into intellectual
property and and patents today you're
managing the high-tech practice of
Reynold Conan Partners initially
Computer Science Background very in war
engineering and then going into
intellectual property yes this was in
fact I
was at the
technical background in
military Air Force and then I started
computer science
and the Masters in the technion IFA
and then I decided that I'll move to uh
the the patent attorney
root I did I was a trainee I qualified
as patent attorney and then I decided to
finalize my education did the 30th law
and a lawyer and that's it for now what
happened tell me a little bit about the
transition
um you know you as an engineer and then
you as a patent attorney what was that
transition like for you what what
prompted that transition what led to it
foreign
I you know it's a good question because
you know also being a software engineer
the the good Prospect the 90s when I and
I graduated from techno
but I was I had this certainly invention
which I filed the patent for in in
Reynold coin with the senior partner at
the time Dr Michel Cohen and he
according to what he told me it seems
like the the direction of software is is
starting to be mature in terms of
possibility of getting patents
and I thought it's you know there were
no patent there were no software
patterns at the time software engineers
at the time
uh within this field and I thought it's
a good opportunity and this was a right
decision I'm happy it was made made 30
years ago and I did not I love it okay
so what happened you know 30 years and
and you know let's even just start you
know even simpler than that what is
pageant attorney I mean what what it
really is it that you do in the day
today
telling you first of all I'm lucky
because most of the people that I I meet
are are smart okay you know this is
great yeah you know I learned it first
years I was a little bit disappointed
but then I said just for a minute you
know instead of Lemon Let's Make a fit
lemonade
and you bet you know you you just learn
from from really smart people
um listen you know it's great job
your mind and your brain has to be you
know in Focus because you're exposed to
the cutting-edge Technologies
and and the and you have to within a
very you know short time understand what
the client is doing sometimes they work
on a project for two years and you have
one hour and a half to understand and to
help them you know to to filter out what
is the the
the the injective concept there it's
very challenging very demanding but with
time and experience
uh you learn to do it in the right way
and if you know you get a nice feedback
from your clients so it's it's it's a
win-win and I what I can tell you
Mikhail is the I say I would say in the
last five years
what's you know great is the things
coincide in the sense that I see more
and more inventors that understand the
value of Ip strategy in their business
and when you meet such a client it's a
great pleasure because you know there is
a true communication we understand what
is the you know what the sea level
executive want and we try to build you
know IP roadmet which will be meet their
business goal and you know great
pleasure so the role of intellectual
property within businesses
um you know it almost feels like
intellectual property feels like you
know to a you know young entrepreneur uh
I I as an entrepreneur now and a COA
learn to understand the importance of it
and the sensitivity behind it but
how relevant really is it in today's
world where software is hitting the
world and anybody you know everything is
democratized and ideas are pretty much
you know worthless in Tech it's all
about execution what is the role of
intellectual property in this world
I'll tell you it's you know it's I would
say
people tend to think about you know
indirect property is very includes very
few paradigms you know pattern in a
trademark designs let's speak about
patterns not the trade secrets and so
forth others are also important but you
know we we only have 20 minutes and not
20 hours so let's try to focus on on
patents and you know people tend to
think about patterns in but I'll speak
in the software in me and say oh just
for a minute you know
well you know I it's swing someone suing
someone is millions of dollars let's
let's keep it
and it's complicated and it will take
resources from us instead of you know
devoting our efforts to r d and business
and they are right we don't believe
although patents you know their purpose
allows you to Sue it's in fact the whole
idea is that you can prevent others from
using your inventive concept if the
patent is granted therefore
but we look at it together with the
c-level executive in a very different
manner not offensive defensive okay
we we what we like to think is to
understand what is the you know what
what what the company is planning to do
in terms of r d
what are the business plans what is the
the VP Business Development plans to do
and our purpose and you know if it's a
startup it's you know it's a moving
Target it changes right every time
startup things change
we our role is to build for them a mind
field
which will follow their r d and Business
Development efforts so that a competitor
who would like to go into their
territory
will encounter rough Terrain
and you know because IP will be another
another obstacle which will hinder the
the the possibility of penetrating to
the territory
it can happen from multinational company
can happen from a competitor it can
happen from a client which became a
competitor
um so all this is is we think it's
defensive wise
and if you build it the right way it can
help you down the road in many many
business scenarios
uh investors obviously you know pass to
liquidity like M A and then you know and
then public offer and so forth but down
the road
tenders a achieving Competitive Edge
vis-a-vis clients compared to your
competition because you have certain
leverage so in many I can give many
examples how it can help you down the
road but it's you know it's like an Iron
Dome it it gives you certain uh
protection and allows you to achieve
your business goals and r d efforts the
process that you work generally with
entrepreneurs on validating and
protecting intellectual property so if I
as an inventor I'm coming in with my own
unique technology unique algorithm idea
Etc
what is the mileage that I need to do
with you and how do I do it so that I
can actually make it defensible and and
something that would actually be
beneficial for my business
by the way
let's not forget to have a few minutes
about software and Ai and machine
learning so let's go there that's
awesome some some misconception about
this we are going to come here to be
very fragile you don't need to do much
what do you mean you don't need to do
much we need to have a chat we need to
have a discussion if you explain to me
what is your business let's say that you
are a CEO and in the meeting also I'd
like to have the CTO and the VP Business
Development
guys what is your business what do you
want to achieve in the in the in the in
the no what next year next two years who
knows what will happen in five years
and what are your r d achievements so
far and plans these are the building
blocks
which together will be will build an IP
strategy and reduce it to IP roadmap
so that down the road will be you know
we don't believe in one patent there
will be more and more patents which will
Embrace what you guys are doing
the more time passes you'll have a more
a stronger and more efficient minefield
which as I said will help you against
competition and and will help you to
achieve the
so in simple words you don't have to
prefer 20 Pages 50 pages things you know
sit with the management for for hours
over hours before you contact us no
we'll do this journey together bye
and then there you know it can be
reduced to technicalities we'll say that
we identify five patent applications you
know we instruct you what need to do
ABCDE and we'll tell you how much it
costs and we help you build budget and
so okay but the discussion the
discussion with the c-level executive
is the key you know is the key point in
understanding what you guys are doing
and building you know customized IP IP
roadmap to what you guys are doing and
changing it change it as your r d and
business changes yeah that makes a lot
of sense you can't do it one time and
fire and forget because it will no
longer be relevant in six months or one
year one hundred percent
now do you want can I can I it's can I
see something about software and then I
was just about to ask listen software
you know many have they believe forget
software why shouldn't be filed back and
for software you know it's it's any I
will hit them and if I write software
someone will change one line of the code
then you know you're out of the patent
and how will I litigate it and you know
many many and maybe you know in
particular for machine learning why
should I do it you know it's a black box
who knows what's going on in this black
box so I should write that so I want to
tell you know it's very important for
for those who listen for us listen
listen to this podcast and and our in
this field
I'll say a simple statement in most of
the legend jurisdictions U.S Europe
China Korea Japan Taiwan Israel India
and so forth you can get a software
related patent and it is enforceable so
this is a and it's not going to change
so first of all you have to be aware of
this fact why this is important
because even if you don't believe in
patents in software
bear in mind that this is not
necessarily the case with your
competition
because the number of software patents
you know every few years double itself
so if you don't believe in patents you
say listen I'll only rely on my r d and
my business development achievements but
your competition files and get patents
eventually you'll have to explain
to your investors or to your potential
buyer
what happens where is there how they can
maintain the Competitive Edge that you
achieved compared to the competition
which are you know loaded with patents
so that's the thing to remember okay
you can definitely benefit
from software patents as we say if you
look at it from the standpoint of the
defensive if you look for example on a
an AI on machine learning you know you
can get
a patterns for for all for for paradigms
of training the machine learning of
architecture sometimes you have a unique
architecture of the machine learning you
can benefit for you can get patterns for
this so there are lots of patterns and
you can see them in many many fields
that are granted applied in the field of
machine learning and AI which as we know
is now you know you can see it
everywhere Precision medicine digital
Healthcare cyber security drones any you
know Ai and machine learning is
everywhere so if this if your product
includes an important component that
pertains to AI machine learning as a
responsible Co it would be a big mistake
to ignore it to say lesson it's not
enforceable let's move on you may find
eventually the competition having
patents which will cause you problem
when you want to pursue your business
goals
how involved then is the sort of the
engineering team or the entrepreneur in
the State of Mind in other words you
know if I'm mapping out now the
involvement that I would imagine of
different different leaders within our
organization you know how how frequent
should this be a topic of conversation
or thinking process
for for us in the day today I'll tell
you
I you know we understand the nature of
our clients they are busy guys
including ladies we see the more
entrepreneurial women that we see we're
happier
we don't we understand it when they call
us they are hot they are not busy
hundred percent they are busy hundred
and twenty percent
so we need to be efficient
so we are doing you know one or two
strategic meetings could be two or three
hours each meeting and we and we
crystallize the high level you know
strategy
and then we reduce it to to to X amount
of patent applications which you may
assign the inventors you know the the
specific Engineers possibly under the
leadership of the CTO we take the
responsibility you know we take the
burden the heavy lifting to our side
because they are busy
we write the patent application they'll
have to read and comment but we try to
shift as much as we can't effort to our
end and frequently it can be every three
months we meet the management and see
what's new if they have anything if you
have good communication with the silver
executive if they come across some
business event they call us so it's not
that now they have to shift the change
all the schedule yeah that makes sense
where where are you situated in all of
this so you mentioned that you're very
lucky we talked very briefly about the
transition from 30 years ago tell me a
little bit more about
you know your experience you know in
this in this world and and how how has
that experience changed or transformed
over the years
um
what we see is as soon as you know a
strategical and attaching a minute you
know that I I I I guess that the some of
our listeners would be interested how
you know the new developments that we
see now in the last year affect IP with
you know the interest rate and then the
and so forth
um
listen you know for me
I've seen many clients who came to me
with a power port presentation
sweat Blood Money
and went all the way until Pastor
liquidity whether they were you know
purchased or or floated to as a public
company
and we need
to follow their progress
so you know when they come with a
PowerPoint with a a a press seed of one
hundred thousand dollars which they have
of obviously tons of missions to do with
this ad we have to offer them
one way of protecting their IP which is
very different when they are post round
B
with the 60 million dollars
raised and they are now thinking on the
way you know to be unicorn
and and so so we have to build a
different IP strategy for this and and
we had a lot we had many many companies
who work in you know some some name
dropping where the you know visual lead
in which Alibaba bought it's the first
investment of Alibaba in Israel so we
learned a lot about the Chinese market
where the equivalent was sold to a
Microsoft and we have with the
store-wise we sold to IB many many
companies that went all the way from
start to end
each such company teaches us or call
photonics which was sold to Samsung and
many many other examples each set such
event teaches us teaches us more
and allows us
to give better advice for the next
client
I see as I told the Mikhail initially
now that you see more and more
experienced entrepreneurs who do their
second time or third time you know start
up
and now they come more educated and more
willing to to cooperate
in building a better business but also a
better IP you know IP plan for their new
startup and we are happy to play in this
game and provide our modest advice to
help this to happen incredible if there
was one or two pieces of advice that you
would give to young entrepreneurs
perhaps first-timers that aren't
necessarily thinking more or maybe are
thinking about this world of
intellectual property what what you know
what resonates that would be really
beneficial for us to be considering as
we go on our journey
okay
it's a good question let me think 30
seconds I would say
any stage
of your startup you cannot ignore
intellectual property maybe you think
that if you have only two hundred
thousand dollars
which you need you need to hire
engineers and you need to do a prototype
and you need to do your first client and
you need and so forth you say Okay IP
will now you know be in my priority
number then no
you have to you have to go to a
professional
and discuss and understand that you are
not making a mistake so this is one
thing IP should be in your cash memory
if you're in the c-level executives this
is one thing maybe you'll hear and say
no I still prioritize my money to do
different things but at least
no this is one thing
and the second thing it's not a one-time
game
it's not that you can do you know you
say okay I'm taking our advice I to go
to the top patent attorneys okay I have
no plan I can show my investors and I
put this aside and now I'm dealing with
the real thing which is r d in business
development which is true this is the
real thing but you have to look again at
you know to to check whether at any
stage
your intellectual property your your IP
roadmap
fits your r d and Business Development
effort so these are the two pieces of
information
you know two tips that I would suggest
any young entrepreneur to bear in mind I
really thank you so much uh this is
really really enjoyable and interesting
and I really am looking forward to
sharing this with everybody so thank you
for the time for the insights and uh
continue helping innovators and
inventors and you know be very
thoughtful and regress with with what
they're doing and the quality of what
and the you know the defensive offensive
nature of what they're doing and
understanding what it means to to
protect it so thank you very much stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you bihail I just wanted to add
one comment you know we face you know in
the last years some difficulties but we
know that crisis is the time where good
startups emerge
and uh so don't ignore IP even in this
difficult uh period uh you know it will
be beneficial both for for good startups
uh down the road wonderful my pleasure
thank you very much
oh